whereas to solve the proportion and we
have 836 is equal to 10 over what or 8
to 36 or the ratio of 8 over 36 is equal
to the ratio of 10 to what and there's a
bunch of different ways to solve this
and I'll explore really all of them or
not all of them are a good selection of
them so one way to think about is these
two need to be equivalent ratios or
really equivalent fractions so whatever
happened to the numerator also has to
happen to the denominator so what do we
have to multiply 8 by to get 10 well you
could multiply 8 times 10 over 8 will
definitely give you 10 so we're
multiplying by 10 over 8 over here or
another way to write 10 over 8 10 over 8
is the same thing as 5 over 4 so we're
multiplying by 5 over 4 to get to 10
from 8 to 10 well if we did that to the
numerator in order to have an equivalent
fraction you have to do the same thing
to the denominator you have to multiply
it you have to multiply it times 5 over
4 and so we could say this n this thing
that we just solve for this n is going
to be equal to 36 times 5 divided by 4
or you could say that this is going to
be equal to 36 times 5 divided by 4 and
now 36 divided by 4 we know what that is
we could divide both the numerator and
the denominator by 4 you divide the
numerator by 4 you get 9 divide the
denominator by 4 you get 1 you get 45 so
that's one way to think about it 8 over
36 8 over 36 is equal to 10 over 45
another way to think about it is how
much what do we have to multiply by 8 by
to get its denominator how much larger
is the denominator 36 then 8 well let's
just divide 36 over 8 so 36 over 8 is
the same thing as so we can simplify
dividing the numerator in the
denominator by 4 that's there that's the
greatest common divisor that's the same
thing as 9 halves so when you if you
multiply the numerator by 9 halves you
get the denominator so we're multiplying
by 9 halves to get the denominator over
here well then we have to do the same
thing over here if this if 36 is 9
halves tying
xate let me write this 36 or let me
write 8 times 9 halves is equal to is
equal to 36 all right that's how we go
from the numerator denominator then to
figure out what the denominator here is
if we want the same fraction we have to
multiply by 9 halves again
so then we'll get 10 times 9 halves is
going to be equal to n is going to be
equal to this denominator and so this is
the same thing as saying 10 times 9 over
2 divide the numerator in the
denominator by 2 you get 5 over 1 which
is 45 so 45 is equal to n once again we
got the same way completely legitimate
way to solve it now sometimes when you
see a proportion like this sometimes
people say oh you could cross multiply
and you can cross multiply and I'll
teach you how to do that and that's
sometimes a quick way to do it but I
don't like teaching it the first time
you look at proportions because it's
really just something mechanical you
really don't understand what you're
doing and it really comes out of a
little bit of algebra and I'll show you
the algebra as well but if you don't
understand it if it doesn't make as much
sense to you at this point don't worry
too much about it so we have 8 over 36
is equal to 10 over N when you cross
multiply you're saying that the
numerator here times the denominator
over here is going to be equal to so 8
times n is going to be equal to the new
the denominator over here the
denominator over here let me do this in
a different color the denominator over
here times the numerator over here this
is what it means to cross multiply so
this is going to be equal to 36 times 10
36 times 10 or you could say you could
say let me do this in a neutral color
now you could say that 8 n is equal to
360 and so you're saying 8 times what is
equal to 360 or to figure out what that
times what is you divide 360 divided by
8 so we could divide and this is a
little bit of algebra here we're
dividing both sides of the equation by 8
and we're getting n is equal to 360
divided by 8 and you know you can do
that without thinking in kind of strict
algebraic terms you say 8 times what is
360 well 8 times 3
sixty over eight if I write eight times
question mark is equal to 360 well
question mark could definitely be 360
over eight if I multiply these out this
guy and that guy cancel out and it's
definitely 360 and that's why it's 360
over eight but now we want to actually
divide this to actually get a right
answer or a simplified answer eight goes
into 360 eight goes into 36 4 times 4
times 8 is 32 you have a remainder of 4
bring down the 0 8 goes into 40 five
times five times eight is 40 and then
you have no remainder and then you have
no remainder and you're done once again
we got n is equal to n is equal to 45
now the last way I'm going to show you
involves a little bit of algebra if any
of the ways before this work that's fine
and where this is sitting in the
playlist you're not expected to know the
algebra but I want to show you the
algebra just because I wanted to show
you that this cross multiplication isn't
some magic that using algebra we will
get this exact same thing but you can
stop watching this if you'll find in
this part confusing so let's let's
rewrite our proportion 8 over 36 is
equal to 10 over N and we want to solve
we want to solve for n well the easiest
way to solve for n is maybe multiply
both this thing on the left is equal to
this thing on the right so we can
multiply them both by the same thing and
the Equality will still hold so we could
multiply both of them both of them by n
on the right hand side the ends cancel
out on the left hand side we have 8 36
times n is equal to 10 now if we want to
solve for n we can literally multiply if
we want if we want just an N here we
could we would want to multiply this
side times 36
do that in a different color we want to
multiply this times this side times 36
times 8 because if you multiply these
guys out you get 1 and you just have an
N but since we're doing it to the left
hand side we also have to do it to the
right hand side so times 36 over 8 these
guys cancel out and we're left with n is
equal to 10 times 36 is 360 over 8 and
no
we're getting the exact we're getting
the exact same value that we got with
cross multiplying and with cross
multiplying you're actually doing you're
actually doing two steps actually doing
an extra step here your multiplying both
sides by n so that you get your a 10 and
then you're multiplying both sides by 36
so that you get your 3 your your 36 on
both sides and you get this value here
but at the end when you simplify it
you'll get the exact same answer so
those are all different ways to solve
this proportion probably the most
obvious way or the easiest way to do it
in your head was well either just
looking at what you have to multiply the
numerator by and then doing the
denominator doing the same thing of the
denominator or maybe by cross
multiplication